so we're going to do something a little
bit fun and interesting today
um petar famously won a competitive
programming competition didn't you well
yes I did I did win a few
um
uh bronze and silver medals at the
acmicpc Regionals which uh I guess
wouldn't equate to winning a programming
competition but surely ranking
reasonably High among Northwestern
Europe University amazing
so I'm I'm going to give you folks a
problem to say and I'm not interested in
the algorithm I'm interested in the data
structures that are used to get the best
asymptotics so we're going to build a
cache
and you can imagine there's some cash
class which has a get
and a set method the get method I want
to have constant asymptotics
and the set method needs to be as fast
as possible but we'll get to that so the
cache just stores a whole bunch of items
and I'll give you an example of what
these items are so we can have C equals
new
cash
and 5 means it's got a maximum number of
five items so this might be YouTube
videos or something in the server will
catch fire if there's more than a
billion items so we need to have a very
efficient way of storing these items and
we can set some new items so we can say
C dot set
and we can say key equals B so this is
the key
and that's a string
the value
now this can be anything so I'll just
kind of say it's it's an object doesn't
really matter and then priority
equals five and expiration
I'm gonna have to
you can use an eraser if you want oh
yeah cheers
and the expiration
equals
1001 so this is an example of how we put
something in the cache
so let's put some other values in so
we'll put a
which should have gone first but it
doesn't matter and as a value of 5 and a
priority of one and an expiration of
that number and then C which has a value
of 3 a priority of five and an
expiration of one oh one and D
which has a value of two
a priority of nine and an expiration of
500.
and finally e
which has a value of one
priority of five and an expiration of
one
now um the only trick to this is when
you set an item if the cache is at
capacity we need to evict one of the
items and the eviction rule has two
components if the item has expired
so expired means that this number is
greater than the system time
and the system time let's say is 900.
okay sorry less than less than the
system time
if it's expired then you remove one of
the expired items will you evict it if
there are no expired items then of the
least of the lowest priority you remove
the least recently used
and least recently used as something
that we're not yet tracking
so um just as an example if we needed to
evict these things using the two rules
that I've just said
so you can see clearly that this is
expired
so using rule a we would get rid of that
none of the other ones have expired
so then we say of the lowest priority
which is this guy there's only one one
so we would get rid of that one
and then there's two fives and then
which is least recently used well had we
done C dot get
let's say C at the bottom
so had we gotten that one
then that would be the most recently
used so we would get rid of that one and
then that one
so which data structures would we use to
do this
all right it's very interesting very
interesting question I would just like
to get some clarification on the second
rule so okay so there is a rule to if
something has expired that goes away
first and it doesn't matter which one we
remove out of the expired ones like uh
there's you don't take into account
priority and stuff like that you just a
random one right the two rows are
completely yeah and then if there's
nothing which expired out of the still
in cash things and you still need to
evict then you first hunt for the thing
with the lowest priority and evict that
and if there are multiple things with
the lowest priority then you choose the
the least recently used one correct just
to make sure okay so we have an
algorithm in there and I guess we don't
care about the size of the keys if you
want the get to be of one
um I mean yeah I assume it's all of One
by just you know fetching a reference
right so that probably to me sounds like
a hash table of sorts right yeah but
isn't that like logarithmic and the size
of the key sure yeah like that's true
but yeah I assume it abstracts the way
that because you know like there's some
complexity just in parsing the key that
you give to it right so if you give it a
huge key right it's gonna be there's
gonna be some complexity just with
reading it so I guess the constant is
like assuming that these keys are
constant space then the whole thing is
constant right okay yeah
so let's see
I so the way I would approach this
problem is like I would try to think
about enforcing the rules in order of
priority so there's going to be
potentially two levels to this data
structure one which is like mindful of
which things have expired and which ones
have not to allow me to like quickly
find something from the from the expired
file if that makes sense
um so
so basically uh
one thing that we could do is maintain
some kind of collection of uh expired
things
right
and specifically in such a way that we
can like once we know something's
expired we can very quickly retrieve a
random one right
so to me this sounds like uh
you know all you need really there is a
is a list of some sort of of things
which have expired and you can add stuff
to that list as you discover new expired
things
but you kind of keep track of that but
it doesn't have to be more complicated
right so yeah
thank you yeah so you don't the like
that's why I asked him like for things
which have expired priorities don't
matter you just take a random one so
like if I'm gonna store things which
have expired it doesn't have to be
anything special right
um and the priority queue would mean you
have like logarithmic cost to insert
into it and take out of it right of
course and what's the priority key under
the covers uh well I guess it depends on
what you use right it can be a binary
Heap Fibonacci Heap stuff like that
right but uh say if it's a binary heat
priority queue then it's a logarithmic
complexity to insert and remove from it
right
so so yeah I think the list would make
the most sense for the for the actual
kind of storing the things which have
expired and then every time I guess get
or set is called okay no get has to be
constant time so we cannot do any funky
stuff and get but like every time set is
called we can run a sweep for uh which
things have expired so far if we don't
have anything in the expired pile if
that makes sense
right but keep
required to keep arranging them and
swapping them but you don't need to
arrange them right keep moving them
isn't all we need to be able to grab the
oldest one all right uh that's a saying
you always have access like you don't
actually need all the expired ones you
just need one
you just need for each set right you
just need to pick one expired one
exactly so you don't need the list of
expired because you're not going to use
only okay yeah so actually that that
that is a good idea in the sense that
we're probably gonna incur some
logarithmic cost anyway for the priority
arrangements and stuff so we might as
well keep everything in a priority queue
by age uh by by expiration because then
you know removing something amounts to
just popping the top of the Heap I guess
which is fine okay so then I guess this
is fine yeah so I think we all don't
know if
I don't know if it breaks
breaks like in the last position and you
have set of then it's working are we is
in general is there not very many
priorities like this is sort of
suggesting I was going to ask but I
think they can be arbitrary numbers
right yeah
so so okay so first component is
absolutely it needs to scale to at least
Millions yeah
so we have a priority queue which is
keyed by expiration
because we don't care and this can be
for example a binary Heap right so this
now guarantees us that we can insert
items into this Heap logarithmically and
we can very cheaply look up is the item
at the top which is by definition the
oldest item in terms of expiration
whether it satisfies the time constraint
right so if the item at the top of the
queue satisfies a time constraint then
you just do a pop on the Heap and you
well we need to talk about gets as well
I think forget we need like a separate
hash table effectively and then whatever
key is at the top of that Heap we need
to remove it from the hash table that
sort of makes it
because otherwise you're not going to
get constant time access like you need a
hash table to get constant time gets
right so maybe at point zero which maybe
we should have said first but I kind of
thought it was implied like you need a
hash table
forgets
so this is like something that Maps just
something simple it Maps keys to values
doesn't have to store any additional
information because all the subsequent
data structures will give us keys to
remove if we need to remove that one one
slight hint to give you is
there'll be another data structure for
priorities yeah and when you move when
you remove a priority you might also
need to remove it out of the expiry Heap
right and deleting something from the
middle of the Heap is linear time right
right yes that is true so we'll get back
to different well that might that just
means we might want to use a binary
search tree instead of a binary key but
we'll get to that like yeah like this is
something you know you iteratively
refine it as you realize what the
constraints are but yes that is that we
would have hopefully realized that
or or you know or if you um or if you
know that your keys will be embeddable
uh by all bit strings of a certain
Universe up to say n dimensional you
could use web trees which are log log M
to both insert and remove so you can do
better than a binary search tree but
okay that's that's Advanced algorithms
material right there anyway so hash
tables will allow us to do constant time
insertion
manipulation deletion of things that we
actually do forgets so get will only
ever interact with this thing right
so we have this we said it's a priority
queue we said it's a binary Heap for now
we know that might have to change but if
we assume it's a binary Heap it gives us
a login for popping right and for
insertion
which is what we need to do right to
insert things by expiration and then pop
the thing at the Top If it's uh if it's
less than the current system time sorry
if it's bigger than the current system
time and then in that case we then also
just well whenever we decide to evict
something we just also remove it from
the hash table which is a constant
additional kind of cost on on average so
we have covered successfully the case
for
um for expiration now we have to talk
about priorities
and okay so the first thing we need
just just one thing on that and so we we
have a tree of expirations yeah but um
there could be collisions yes
yes there could be uh so there could be
collisions but you can define a custom
comparator for that right like you can
say uh
either expiration of a is less than
expiration of B in which case a is less
than b or expiration of a is equal to
expression of B and the key of A is less
than key of B so basically you use the
key to fall back to the keying function
if the if the Expressions Clash so
that's fine in terms of organizing the
data structure interesting yeah okay I
mean you can build a heap like that like
you just Define what less than means uh
based on this because as we said as you
told us we can use arbitrary elements to
evict them if they're expired so then it
doesn't matter how we rearrange things
which have expired and how do you link
the um the elements from the Heap back
to presumably you're using a hash table
keyed on on the key here yeah so so this
priority queue as we said it's keyed by
this Tuple of expiration and key so when
we extract the Min it will tell us the
expiration of that item as well as the
key of that item so we can then use that
key to evict from the hash table correct
yeah so now we have to deal with the
next thing which is to arrange things by
priority and I think for that the
backbone can still be a priority queue
of some kind right which which is keyed
By Priority but why do you need a
different priority yeah because because
this one will just arrange by expiration
but you can use composed right like the
key for the priority queue can be a like
a formula from expiration
and priority as well right right so you
could basically invent a custom
comparison function which takes into
account both of those things
yeah yeah actually you could yes like
you could say like if expert no but I
think the problem is that you want to
give like infinite priority here for
things that have expired and that kind
of changes through time so you would
have to kind of reorder the entire Heap
every time the system time changes which
is like uh linear time so that's a
problem but you can put when it was less
access that's an information right and
then you can just compute this was the
expiration at this time and now I'm
accessing that this time and I'm in any
case like somehow the entire hard part
right is like the last access being able
to update the last access fast I mean I
imagine what's gonna happen is we're
gonna have some another priority queue
for these priorities and then they will
index into some kind of circular list of
things at a particular priority but we
can figure that out as we go along right
the I'm kind of trying to kind of
peel away this onion structure of
constraints right so this one here deals
with the expiration now we can design
one that deals just with priorities
assuming all priorities are different
and then we can deal with clashes and I
feel like that's kind of a nice
hierarchical way to approach this right
so so for this one like you need to find
the item with the highest priority so
this literally screams priority queue to
me one more time right yeah with the
with the the comparison function now
bubbles up the highest priority items
yeah sure depends on yeah and computer
systems I guess usually the lower
priority is actually the higher priority
but
I mean
we're gonna we're gonna get to last
access right yeah no no but the problem
is like this get right this this get now
needs to change last access right which
means it can't do anything logarithmic
so like so that's that's going to be the
there's going to be an interesting hash
table in here that will link the key to
where it lives in this priority queue
and and that's kind of going to allow us
to kind of pointwise update the least
recently accessed item uh and that's
yeah that's that's the dream we will
figure it out hopefully okay right
so priority queue keyed by priority
interface
[Music]
um
so once again for now this is a binary
key but I imagine that as we end up
having to delete things across things
this will have to become a binary search
tree or something
so this here is when we insert a new
item uh it gets inserted based on its
priority and currently we're assuming
there's no two items with the same
priority so this just gets inserted and
we call extract Min on this one if the
top of this one hasn't expired right
so
push and
track them in
if one hasn't
extracted
and now the
the hint which Tim mentioned surfaces
because
depending on which of these two queues
you pop from you need to delete from the
other one right so that means you need
to support an efficient delete operation
which for heaps are linear time so we
need binary search trees or better I
guess like a red black tree or something
have fun fact I've never actually
implemented a full red black tree
and how do they work in principle just
in in a couple of sentences yeah sure I
mean so they're generally this idea of
you want to keep the tree balanced so to
sort of like uh so that the the biggest
path you take down the tree is you're
searching for items doesn't grow
linearly with the size of the tree but
rather logarithmically and to do to
ensure that your binary surgery stays
balanced under any possible order of
insertions you need to perform these
kinds of rotations such that the tree
balances itself because there are
operations these rotations that take you
from a tree to an equivalent tree like
one that is still a valid binary search
tree which stores exactly the same
information but in a way that now the
diameter of this tree is smaller so the
path length you need to get to a leaf is
less and red black trees deals with this
analogy by coloring the vertices red and
black and then there's a variety of
rules that red and black colors must
satisfy and I don't exactly remember
like the leaves must be black and then
you cannot have a red note cannot have
both red children or something like that
I know you're currently supervising this
stuff maybe you remember the rules
yeah
so soon
but yeah basically you can't have two
consecutive red no too consecutive
rental yes exactly I remember that and
the leaves all need to be black I think
yeah it lives only to be black I
remember that one too Andrew do you
remember the red black churros no
no okay
so we have
balanced BST for both of these and now
we have log n delete as well
although deletes are really tricky to
implement in practice
okay
and you can still have logarithmic time
to find the minimum in a binary search
tree because you just go left left left
left left until you hit the smallest
element
okay
so now we have a solution for everything
except for the least recently used part
so we're I think we're making progress
um so now
like I mean I had to do at least
recently used caches as an interview
exercise long time ago so I sort of
remember but this queue now doesn't
store just one item because there can be
multiple items with the same priority
and what I what I would say is it should
store a collection of items
which have that priority so now this
push operation right it's not just it's
first find if this item already exists
in the binary search tree if not insert
it with a single element collection
if it doesn't exist sorry if it does
exist add it to that collection
and assign it the the the item that is
most recently used kind of value
is that does that sort of make sense
so it's like
we have our
well ideally I should be coloring these
nodes red and black but whatever so
there's a priority P1 and then there
might be since this is a okay bad choice
priority two priority one priority zero
okay this should be priority two and
this is priority three because it's in
order
and priority four
so each one of these nodes would now be
pointing
to some collection of uh items right
right but there should definitely be a
key in there right and there should be
so there's there's some kind of Tuple I
guess which contains the key and
contains the access time
yeah right and now because get needs to
update this access time we need to have
right we need to have a direct link from
this key not just to the value
but to this entry over here
and this is we can create a reference to
this and assign it to this hash table
over here so it's whenever get is called
you can kind of immediately update the
access time of this guy using the system
time
does that that sounds doable right and
then you've got cool set you can
change those references we need to be
able to get the most the least recently
accessed yes right so how do we support
logarithmic what oh Vlog and pop but o
of one like re-insert like
so
um
basically uh like I don't think that we
need to physically store these access
times because a list might be a
sufficient representation of all the
things we've accessed
because what does it mean to access
something you look it up okay let's
let's rewrite this to be more explicit
right like there's a this is pointing to
a tail of a list which keeps all the
items right so key uh key key and then
this key from a hash table points into
that list right so now when an item is
accessed what you do you keep a pointer
to the head of the list you move you
splice it onto the top of the list which
is a constant time operation right you
only need to rewire a constant number of
pointers to do that and then when you
need to do least recently used you just
take the item which is at the bottom and
that's it okay what happens when you
need to snip it in the middle
when you need to step it in the middle
so if you delete an expiry you'll also
need to delete it out of this guy right
you you store the the pointers because
these guys point now not just the values
but to pointers in this list so you can
just do a constant Timeless deletion and
splice the pointers it needs to be a
doubly linked list yeah yeah yes yes yes
yes
so you need to know what's behind as
well as what's forward yes yes so this
is this is all sounding very good so
what's the asymptotics of our set
should we log in I'm thinking this is
actually okay
log n okay so first of all
so here n is the overall number of items
for example
here well like the number
expirations yeah uh yes yes
well no actually as I said we're kind of
we can modify the comparison function to
allow for clashes in the expression like
that's that's not a problem so this can
be a log n where n is literally the
number of items in the cache at any
point right
and uh here the all the list operations
seem to be constant time right like
there's no real effort there so it's
this works because when we set something
it's never been used before right yes
that's the trick right you always put it
at the head of the list when it's new
right so so the overall complexity is
the complexity of traversing down so
it's log number of unique priorities
effectively
um now I will say so this is the
complexity of of our of our structure so
log size of cache but with the caveat
that you could use a
I think you can use a web tree
which will decrease this to log log of
number of items wow so I'm not
completely sure but as long as you have
the constraint that the that your keys
can be kind of expressed as bit strings
from a particular Universe then you can
do all the associative array operations
in log log end time and how would you
amortize both of those traversals
uh uh good question so
uh you mean as in like these two
traversals or yeah so why isn't it the
expiration and the product yeah yeah
so
I mean the thing is
It's tricky to do amortized analysis in
this context right because X you can
always give adversarial expirations that
will force you to always pop here
whereas you might always do you know
like
different Explorations that will always
make you pop here right so it's like if
we're doing worst case analysis uh this
guy here has more items in it and
therefore log of number of items in the
cache dominates I guess
um
but uh yeah although we could yeah I
mean if if we want to kind of exploit
the statistics of the data we could also
have like log of unique priorities log
of unique explorations to like but
that's only if we expect there to be
like a fixed number of unique priorities
but but then we might want to do some if
we know there's a fixed number of unique
priorities then we don't need this
complicated search tree we can literally
do like buckets right so Priority One
points to one list priority two points
to another list and so on right so that
then we could even go into constant time
for for the for that particular part
so there must be some amortization trick
though for this kind of access like the
first one yeah I think this is more your
area of expertise than mine Andrew the
amortizations part is it I mean I I
certainly don't know off the top of my
head
like basically if we're doing worst case
there's not much you can do because you
can always force it to do all the work
here or all the work here that's like in
terms of traversals
um
amazing well um I better I would have
hired you
good to know no no the last time I've
done lru caches in an interview question
was
2015 so it's been a long time a long
time since I last had to recall this
yeah and would that be a Google by any
chance that was for Google actually yeah
yes no not that you're allowed to
mention the secret squirrels interview
question
yeah cool well um that was amazing thank
you so much folks very enjoyable thank
you